moi je ne soutiendrai pas une approche
qui serait une approche exclusivement
droitière je suis pour une alliance de
la droite et du centre
et je ne vois pas comment on gagne dans
la république française sans une
alliance de la droite et du centre
donc je ne soutiendrai pas une démarche
qui conduirait à ce qu'il y ait une
radicalisation à droite du parti auquel
j'appartiens toujours mettons plus
incarner sai on a aujourd'hui un côté
wauquiez d'un côté solaire de 2 nous
verrons nous verrons à l'intérieur des
républicains qui peut incarner ce combat
nous verrons comment les choses peuvent
se présenter
la madame pécresse s'est retiré et
xavier bertrand cirest laurent wauquiez
franchement soyons soyons tous prudents
à le jeu de nom est un peu et un peu
modeste parce que quand on voit ce
comment on s'est tous trompés sur les
légumes présidentielle si l'élection dlr
je pense que pour moi l élection et
l'air elle est un peu anticipée je pense
qu'elle aurait été mieux si c'était un
peu plus tard parce que je crois
vraiment que on a des clarifications à
aborder et je crois que nos électeurs
veulent qu'on parle plus de la france
que de notre parti et ce qui compte
aujourd'hui si on fait de la politique
c'est pas la politique pour que notre
parti gagne c'est la politique pour que
la france réussisse et que on apporte
nos idées à la france et donc je crois
que on donne le sentiment on a fait des
primaires conduirait une dizaine de mois
et maintenant on repart dans une
élection de partisane je crois qu'on est
à côté des préoccupations de l'opinion
publique donc ça ça me parait est une
erreur stratégique pour l'avenir une du
parti pour ce qui me concerne moi je
préfère faire en sorte que monsieur
macron quand il nous propose des choses
positives on le soutient et quand ils
proposent des choses avec lesquelles on
n'est pas d'accord on essaie de corriger
la copie